it looks like y'all have been hard at
work discovering things in Hogwarts
Legacy so here even more things found so
far that we wish we knew before playing
let's start with combat if you suddenly
stop gaining experience when fighting
enemies it's a feature not a bug it even
appears the only way to get experience
in Hogwarts Legacy is through Field
Guide book challenges that's not
immediately obvious at first to people
so if you want to gain experience
through combat which a lot of us do
you'll need to accomplish Feats against
different enemy types and once those are
done you need to move on that means
later in the game to advance levels
through combat you need to know what
enemy types you're still after if you
get really stuck in your experience
combat grind in a way that might be
holding you back from higher level armor
dropping in the environment you can go
buy some slightly higher level gear in
hogsmead transfiguring an enemy into a
barrel means they temporarily take on
Barrel properties in physics follow up
with the push spell to pulso and you can
throw them way further you can even
shatter them
the spell accio automatically turns into
ingardium Leviosa if you hold down the
casting button for longer that means you
don't need to take up an extra spell
slot by equipping both spells just use
accio but even better this works on
transfigured enemies who are absolutely
helpless to your shenanigans
The Collection tab in the menu will tell
you an enemy's weakness for example
poetry animagus can be forced out of
their wolf form with a transformation
spell you were paying attention in dark
arts class right
trolls can be cheese pretty easily by
placing a tree between you and them or
by going into a nearby hallway they stay
in very confined areas and won't follow
you
if you go to the South Route and combine
it with dark arts curses a few gear
upgrades and the stealth Talent
petrificus totalus Mastery you can
insecure groups of enemies there are
also some crazy One-Shot stealth builds
people have made videos about with
Talent upgrades stacking three deep on
Armor and these can pretty much
instantly kill anything in the game
consider this build if one of your kids
are playing the game and they're not
quite as good at combat
from our YouTube comments mandrix break
all Shield types which is really helpful
when fighting multiple enemies that are
using different shield types at once
all right so let's talk about some fun
loadouts
for creatures that don't have shields or
wands like spiders and trolls you can go
full send on red damage spells and it is
fun as hell crowd control spells within
this group are also great for spiders
which will flee in all directions when
they catch fire
a good early on dark wizard Loadout is
Expelliarmus to disarm to pulso to get
them away from their wand and then
follow up with your favorite damage
spell of choice
upgrading your disarming spell
Expelliarmus allows you to hit enemies
with their own weapons but don't forget
to hit the throw button after you cast
it
ancient finishers are very contextual so
just for fun pay attention some turn
enemies into tiny bugs that you step on
some turn them into chickens some beat
trolls with their own clubs and some
slam people into nearby obstacles
explore the vivarium in the room of
requirements inside our secret chests
customization unlocks and materials the
vivarium is bigger than you might think
adding traits to gear only takes these
three animals so have them stocked in
your beastiary at all times and build up
the materials they give you early on
level one traits are puff skin level two
are deer calls and level 3 Arc neasels
upgrading gear takes a more diverse set
of beasts but that only becomes
important if you aren't getting levels
fast enough or hit level cap in late
game
so it turns out there are also shiny
beasts hello Pokemon they tend to be a
different color and can be identified by
a star next to their gender in your
inventory breeding two shiny beasts will
give you a shiny Offspring breeding a
shiny and non-shiny Beast can still give
you a shiny Offspring we went off on a
tangent and saw if we could breed shiny
mounts that could duplicate some of the
animals you got from more expensive
versions of the game but despite various
combinations and even trying to sell our
named mounts it didn't seem like that
was possible overall it doesn't seem
like shinies give you anything other
than cosmetic changes they don't give
you more resources or have a higher
resale value but man some of them are
cute
and slide tip while we're in the room of
requirements you can color code your
plant's tables so you can tell between
the deadly ones and the resource ones
let's talk about quality of life you can
use the d-pad to flip between Overworld
Maps instead of having to click buttons
at the top of the screen it is way
faster
if you rush through the tutorial like I
might have you might have missed you can
hold up the d-pad button on controllers
and your Field Guide will show you the
in-game path to where you need to go I
spent way too many hours navigating by
the minimap before glancing over and
seeing one of my kids do this so don't
be me
you can use a broom to get in and out of
water making any water related loot or
quests way easier
you can use the upgraded Dodge teleport
in areas that would normally get you
stuck like marshes or you can even Dash
through those crawl spaces that force
you to go slowly
and you know while we're in quality of
life save yourself the trouble there are
95 Merlin trials but there are only
eight total puzzle types and we don't
recommend going after all of them unless
you're a completionist it's a great way
to burn yourself out in an open world
game you know this if you've played any
open world game it also turns out that
many of them aren't even on the
Overworld map so they are critical to
expanding your initial 20 inventory
slots and maybe do 10 of these and call
it a day more important go for a few
ancient magic hot spots first which
expand your ancient magic meter quickly
letting you store up to three special
attacks
here's some details you might have
missed just like the book The Hufflepuff
common room will really spray you with
vinegar if you're not part of that house
and you try to get in
from the Slytherin common room you see
more people off in the distance and
shooting the glass will anger the Lake's
resident giant squid there's a musician
in hogsmeade who shows up in other
locations and the more you tip him the
bigger his band will grow and sometimes
dragons will show up in the world we've
been told to show up on your map also
and you can select them and then pass
your way to them I couldn't personally
reproduce this but I've seen a couple of
YouTube videos about it
and let's get into some miscellaneous
fun things what does the Sorting Hat
actually do turns out not much you won't
spend a lot of time in your common room
and it doesn't have a storage space or
anything useful there as many of our
commenters pointed out it really just
boils down to meeting certain characters
earlier or later in the game like a meat
who will get you into astronomy
challenges later if you're in Hufflepuff
but he'll be in your room early on if
you're Ravenclaw each house gets one
different starting Quest and some
cosmetic items but just go with whatever
house your heart desires you're not
really missing much that being said if
you have kids that want to play the game
from the main menu screen just start new
characters in new houses you can lower
the difficulty at any time if they're
having trouble and also you can build
them that insane One-Shot stealth build
that we mentioned earlier
and finally of course on PC people are
already modding the game so prepare for
Thomas the Tank Engine to haunt your
dreams and no that is not a bugger I'm
not sure if this is appropriate but it
is highly hilarious there's also Dobby
with a Glock
so let's keep going why don't we miss
that you found playing Hogwarts Legacy
let us know in the comments below and
thanks for watching
Hogwarts Legacy is developed by
Avalanche software a subsidiary of
Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment the game has been
embroiled in controversy due to
transphobic remarks from Harry Potter
author J.K Rowling although she is not
personally involved with its development
she stands to profit from its success
for more on this please see this video's
description for a link to our in-depth
article on how Rowling's comments have
impacted the trans community in this
article you will also find links to
trans creators you can support as well
as Charities you can donate to